stephen braun really wanted to get back
on the mound real quick after his last
outing i expect him to come out today be
much much better and be more like he was
in that perfect three innings against
the cups so two outs here three balls of
two strikes to
cabrera strike three call it's back to
the braults
from chicago to today one two three man
at first man at second two outs were in
the first inning in scoreless it's two
and two to brian reynolds the number
five hitter in this pittsburgh lineup
and
struck him out
second time
that spencer turnbull struck out a
pittsburgh battery first
the one away for candelario
and suddenly a four-pitch walk to jamer
candelario do the demons come back in
his head from the last start or at times
pass where he's a little erratic or does
he make the adjustment slow the game
down and that's what you want to see
with stephen brawl
and he hits kristen stewart putting
runners at first and second four pitch
walk hits the next guy and now you this
is the guy you don't want to see
over the mound second baseman there and
that's what you want to see
good job stephen brault here's kevin
newman who flew out to center his first
time up the first two are on here in the
third can he get a ground ball here
comes the 1-1
swung on went the other way right at
crone they get the force at second and a
double play turn turnbull covered first
base and a job well done by the tigers
defense
bell gets under one sends it to right
for reyes tigers defense helping out
spencer turnbull
here in this third inning well now with
a runner at third and two outs and a
scoreless game it'll be interesting to
see how turnbull and austin romine
approach eric gonzalez
oh
eight up scope and the pirates take a
one-nothing lead
hit on the screws right there it's 104.7
off the bat
moran scores the two out
sharply hit ball
knocked scope down to the ground victor
reyes bounced into a double play his
last timeout
to left field
and deep on the run goes reynolds
that'll bounce up against the wall
reyes hustles into second he's got
himself a one out double second extra
base hit of the tigers sunday afternoon
romaine was the first batter that
stratton faced and he doubled on the
second pitch that he saw stratton's
pitch swinging the ground ball up the
melinda center field of base hit reyes
around third and he will score throw
comes all the way through nope cut off
right in front of the mound by bell
romine delivers again he did it on
friday night rbi single here we're tied
at one here in the fifth number 32 our
jeff hartley
faces the two three four hitters scope
cabrera crone
94 struck him out good looking pitch
there no two count on
cabrera oh man breaking ball gets them
how about that one that's the bad
intentions right there you're tremendous
cj crone
has fly down and struck out
and hits this one deep to left center
field but reynolds
is there
one two three and here's brian reynolds
strikeout in the ground now for reynolds
so far here today
oh yes that is wicked look at it
fourth strikeout of the afternoon for
spencer turnbull we've seen spencer
turnbull not just deal a little bit here
against the pirates but talk to himself
try to get himself in the right frame of
mind and focus terrific start for
spencer turnbull the first time a
tiger's starting pitcher has pitched
into the seventh inning six in a row
retired by turnbull two away and now the
catcher john ryan murphy the one-two
pitch swinging a soft ground ball to the
left of the mountain turnbull field fire
whoa he threw a fastball it looked like
he was heading down the right field line
oh man and crone grabbed it for out
number three bringing up cabrera here in
this tie game in the eighth inning a
couple of strikeouts and a flyout for
cabrera
whoa where'd that go
scope will take second gladly rodriguez
ball slips out of his hands he threw
that one it was somewhere between
halfway between home and third i've
never seen anything quite like that that
is unbelievable single heroes should
give the tigers a lead it's a 1-1 game
in the eighth inning the 3-2 is swinging
a shot base hit into left field charging
his reynolds around third is scope and
he will score without a throw miguel
cabrera delivers with two outs in the
eighth inning and the tigers take a 2-1
lead here's joe jimenez to work the
ninth
joey mena is trying to close this one
out tigers leading two to one two away
in the ninth and here's gerard dyson one
ball two strikes base is empty two outs
the pitch swinging a mess he got him on
strikes and the tigers sweep the pirates
in pittsburgh spencer turnbull's seven
strong innings our final score in
pittsburgh the detroit tigers sweep the
pirates with a 2-1 win